hello everyone and welcome to uh top
Clash on the first Board of the European
Women's Championship it is Olivia colvis
of Poland uh anderina Bulma of Romania
both of them are undefeated so far four
and a half points each this is round six
and it's uh quite uh quite the game uh
if you guys remember in the previous
Olympiad uh both of them played uh Irina
represented Romania on board one she got
a six and a half out of ten which is uh
uh Exquisite on board one and Olivia was
playing board three but she had a 9 out
of nine before before she got her first
draw in the Olympia so I think she ended
on like uh nine and a half out of uh out
of 11 she she lost her last game but
yeah I mean going nine out of nine
that's um I mean that's that's amazing
uh so it's a really big matchup so let's
see how it went it's a really
interesting game with uh not just a king
walk it's it's really a bonk Cloud if if
you will so let's check it out Olivia
has the white pieces and she opens with
Eve 4 we have e 5 9 to F3 Knight to C6
and Bishop to B5 a nice three Lopez with
A6 the morphe defense that should pay
for Knight to F6 and now Knight the C3
the tarash variation uh the Four Knights
of the real Lopez are on the board B5
with Bishop to B3 and here is already
where Irina tries to really confuse or
rather take uh Olivia out of the opening
book she plays Bishop to D6 so usually
everyone plays Bishop to E7 here it's a
really standard move uh video played
against Maxima Shiela gravity and played
it against linear Dominguez aronian
played it against Rapport karwana played
it against chefchenko and it's a fine
opening for both players with with mixed
results out of those games but here we
have Bishop to D6 and this is now uh
rather weird now uh it's very
interesting you can you you could also
consider D6 series it's just um not
really clear what you do after Knight to
G5 so you can't really play D6 so Bishop
did D6 is like D6 only it doesn't allow
nice to G5 because now obviously you can
just Castle but it frees up the Knight
so the Knight doesn't have to guard the
E5 pawn and the Knight now wants to go
after the light Square Bishop right away
so that's kind of the idea and here uh
there are a couple of games that reach
this position where castles was played
but here we have Pawn to D3 and it is
now already as of move 7 then we have a
completely new game so okay uh Irina
continues with her plan ninth day five
goes after the bishop Bishop to G5
continuing development and not Knight
captures on B3 eliminating White's
Bishop's pair eight characters on B3 and
not Bishop to B7 now grabbing hold of
this diagonal D4 uh try to punish this
weird Bishop on D6 now Force D captures
and E5 is the threat which would win
material so e cap percent D4 and now
Queen captures on D4 we have castles and
now it seems like you don't really have
E5 but Olivia goes uh for E5 nonetheless
and okay Bishop actors than F3 and now
Bishop captures an F6 you could consider
some other moves instead of Bishop
captures and F6 like you could play G
captures on F3 it's uh also a
possibility but then comes the bishop
characters on E5 and black is just
better because if you can if you recap
for Rook d8 wins the White Queen and
also after Bishop captures and F3 you
could consider e captures and D6 it's a
similar to the line that actually
happened in the game uh for example now
Rook d8 with checking goes to D2 it's
much safer than an F1 actually King to
D2 Bishop goes back is now the bishop is
hanging here Bishop captures an F6 G
captures and F6 and now let's say Rook 8
to D1 and after Rook the E6 going after
the pawn here the captors Queen captures
and this is something that you would get
which is very similar to what happened
in the actual game but in the game
Bishop captures any F6 was played first
now we have uh G captures and F6 and now
e captures and D6 Rook d8 check King to
D2 and now Bishop the C6 much like in
the line that we've discussed now comes
Rook 8 to E1 not D1 this is what Olivia
goes for uh We've Rook the E6 going
after the uh D6 Pawn D captures on C7
Queen captures and now Rook captures an
E6 the captors on E6 were basically a
huge capture Fest and now Queen captures
an F6 you know that Rook 38 is coming so
you might as well move the queen and now
the problem is uh how do you continue
and here B4 is actually the best move as
it often is in many positions but here
uh some of you were considering probably
Rook 38 would check the problem with
checking right away is that after King
the C1 now B4 isn't as potent because
now you don't have to move the Knight
you can play Rook to D1 that's uh kind
of the the idea now if black trades for
example Knight captures uh Queen
captures an H2 uh Queen to G5 check and
nothing spectacular is happening here uh
you can play F3 and everything is nicely
defended but here after B four it is a
little bit of different now Queen to G5
with the check king th8 queen to F6 with
checking to G8 and now I'm not satisfied
with the repetition uh here Olivia goes
for Knight to D1
and okay now comes Queen to A5 if you go
for Rook to d8 to check now after King
to C1 uh it's playable but how do you
continue Bishop P4 you could threaten
Checkmate now comes Knight E3 in the
Knight here really takes care of
everything you could play Rook to C8
then okay black will put some pressure
uh but probably we we would just see a
draw by repetition here so although it
looks nice nothing really happening
there so instead we have Queen to A5 uh
preparing a very very nasty attack but
she also misses one very crucial idea
and you guys will help help us figure
that out Knights the E3 now Comes The
Rook to d8 with check King te E2 and now
Bishop to B5 with check and now it seems
like we really have nowhere to go the
queen is threatening to continue the
attack along the back rank the bishop is
preventing King to F1 uh The Rook is
completely slicing off the the D file so
what do you play here of course you're
gonna play King to F3 you could also
block with C4 go into an ampa song or
even knife Knight to C4 but King to F3
although it looks very weird it's the
strongest move you can play Queen to C7
now preparing to check the king from C6
to further chase the white king away uh
Ponte H4 and this is how that Olivia
will will uh sort of bonecloud Castle
her king king's side Queen to C6 with
check with King to G3 and now there are
really no more useful checks Queen to C7
check was played now just King to H3 and
now there are no more checks so Rook the
D7 uh Knight to G4 now the Knight can
now come to H6 with check which could be
very deadly also then I can come to E5
uh not a pleasant position for Irina she
goes for H5 attacks the Knight but not
just Queen to G5 with check king of f8
now comes Knight to the F6 attacks The
Rook attacks the pawn here Rook D4 now
preparing to if the Knight moves maybe
you can claim the the the the G4 Square
uh but uh you know not likely Knight
captures and 5 we have rooked the D5 now
attacking the queen and the Knight but
just Queen to H6 with check King t7 and
now Rook back to the uh sorry uh Queen
to F6 check first now King to D6 and now
Queen to F4 with check now you could try
uh running away uh Queen side but first
she goes for Pawn to E5 Queen to F6
would check now King to C5 we have
knighted to the G3 uh returning the
Knight into the game and now you are
very much ready to start advancing your
H Pawn
uh so Bishop D7 check King to H do with
King to B5 and now Rook to E1 and now uh
once the king lands uh you will have
completed your bone Cloud so here we
have Bishop to E6 with Rook to E2 now
guarding the at the C2 Pawn because okay
maybe black uh could have gone after the
pawn but then white would have grabbed
D5 Pawn so they both just defend pawns
A5 and now Ponte H5 we have Ponte E4 now
opening up this diagonal which could be
very important Ponte H6 we have rooked
five attacks the queen queen to G7 and
now Queen to D6 and this queen to D6
sets up a very very deadly trap and I'm
sure you guys see it but just in case
you don't tell me what happens if white
plays Pawn to H7 here feel free to pause
the video and try to punish this silly
move by white uh hypothetical move by
white while I give you a couple of
seconds
foreign
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh true brilliancy and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Rook the H5 check now of course the
Knight cannot move then I spend only
moves King to G1 now comes Queen to D1
with check and okay you could give up
The Rook but that's pretty much
pointless so you're gonna block with
Knight to F1 and now it seems like black
will just capture the uh The Rook here
and then you're gonna promote your Pawn
but no Queen captures an F1 check King
captures only move and Rook to H1 is
Checkmate this is what Irina prepared by
playing Queen to D6 a very tricky idea
but Olivia sports that she of course
doesn't Advance the pawn she plays Rook
captures on e4 which frees up D2 Square
for the white king and now it's no
longer an option but it's still kind of
the best uh the best a series of moves
so Rook to H5 check with King to G1
Queen to D1 check now comes Knight to F1
and offers this is pointless
um uh this is pointless because after
characters you have King E2 so Queen
back to D5 and now we have rooked the D4
attacks the black queen we have a queen
to C5 and now Rook back to D2 defending
the pawn here uh we have Queen to G5
offering a queen trade and also not
allowing that pass Pawn to continue
marching forward and here Olivia just
trades but uh it's uh kind of in her
favor to trade as she is up so much
material so Queen captures Rook captures
and now Rook the d8 preparing turn uh
defend her Pawn uh we have rooked H5
putting the room behind the pass Pawn
but now just Rook to h8 with King to C6
it um uh the the pawn is uh super safe
on H6 it's a dark Square uh she only has
a light score Bishop so you don't really
have to worry about uh anything and you
are up three pawns so this is completely
winning King to C6 was played with
knights the E3 uh King to D7 and now
Pawn to G4 Chase is away the Rook Rook
H4 not just King to G2 and you can't
capture if you capture this would be a
terrible mistake even though you are
defending the pawn knocking G3 with a
double attack you would resign here so
instead King the E7 trying to get the
king closer to that H Pawn but now just
King to G3 chases away The Rook Rook the
H1 Ponte F4 and now Pawn to F6 we have
Pawn to F5 attacks the bishop Bishop D7
now Knights the D5 with check now you
could go uh here to defend your uh F6
Pawn but then Rook H7 check will again
go after the bishop so you might as well
part with the pawn right away King 36
Knight captures an F6 and now Bishop to
C6 we have H7 here and he was in this
position and move 60 that Irina bulmaga
resigned to the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
a great victory for Olivia kyobasa uh
who is now on five and a half out of six
and in sole lead of the women's European
Championship 2023 uh we'll see if she if
she can continue playing in this um in
this style uh as uh we are already
halfway through uh the uh European
Championship so uh her next opponent let
me just check I don't want to trick you
guys uh her next opponent will be a
Monica sochko also uh uh uh a fellow
polish chess player that they played
together in the in the Olympiad so it
will be quite uh quite a match we'll see
we'll see how it goes as Olivia is uh in
Seoul place with uh five and a half
points out of six and a second and third
place are currently Monica sochko uh
with five out of six and the mind narwa
uh also with uh with five out of six uh
from from Estonia uh so yeah uh that's
the game I hope you guys enjoyed it here
you resign because well
uh let's say you give a couple of checks
rules you want king of four Rook to F1
checking G5 there's nothing Rook to H1
you can put the Rook behind the pass
Pawn but one check and you will promote
your Pawn to a queen that's pretty much
it black will have to go up The Rook
captures you're gonna be down a full
rook and uh you know you will get many
queens while while winning this game so
it would be pointless uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it very
nicely done by Olivia kilbasa uh still
undefeated after six rounds of the
women's European Championship we'll see
how it goes uh for the rest of the
tournament I would like to wish a very
happy birthday to nishad and I would
like to thank Richard karp Laurent Andre
gianniscini a revolution reptiles
YouTube and Kathleen North Thorpe uh for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day